hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a brand new let's play of
underhell now this is a very interesting
game that actually has been on my list
for a while and it's only got the
prologue released so far but it's
actually being grimm greenlit on steam
soon it's a very interesting premise of
a house and some exploration I'm not too
sure of the details I haven't liked all
the games I don't read up on the details
because I want to have most of the
experience to be new and fresh okay if
this is the first time you play it we'll
start a new game to return to the house
as you left it click continue to reset
the house use the select chapter menu
hang on okay I think I think this is
gonna start a new game anyway okay very
very curious because I've heard a lot of
good things is exceptionally highly
rated on ModDB and I mean for a free
thing hey I'm one of the plain I'm
willing to give any India or game a try
you know just to get the word out there
because indie horror is like exploding
in popularity too I mean it's fun to
watch it's fun to play it's fun for a
lot of things so let's see how this does
hello oh no oh no did we freeze on the
loading screen Oh
well I guess it's just you and me now no
game to entertain us in all hmmm now
that's a damn shame it's made on the
source engine I would assume that it's
gonna be very stable okay I'm gonna go
away and cut back in when the game
starts good and we're back alright so I
had to fix some problems obviously now
you can hear something how strange that
is that we're boom boom boom boom all
right so I got a reset yes start a new
game because there's some sort of
dynamic with the house the house is like
a perpetual thing in the game where you
can always come back to it I'm not sure
but either way I'm ready to go again and
hopefully this doesn't freeze at the dah
hello
gee oh hi Jay can you hear me my name's
not Jake buddy hang in I'm gonna take
care of you buddy
ain't your buddy pal all right all right
oh hello MX love presents
in collaboration with we create stuff
very nice intro
and s modification and s mod
modification for half-life 2
very well done introduction
hello
yeah
I picked up on them
oh my belts are yep I do that
yeah Tom stopple
directed by MX
project is how did I overlook this what
is curious because this is like
exceptionally involved you know like on
the level of nightmare how stupid I'm
Arastoo didn't have a intro like that
I'd like to think that people that make
source mods try to put as much work as
possible
like it I like it loud what a lovely
lovely house ooh a glowy look like he's
he'll Oh uh-oh I just woke up who's
there huh crying yeah I don't I don't
know what that means
okay saved time to go to work I need to
put my gear from the brush look um food
her head Jake man how you holding up huh
huh I guess that's a stupid question I
know you got franken you guys are tight
but I'm serious man yeah me too
mmm Mike cried man I mean you're not
alone I'm serious man Collison let's go
have a drink oh man deepest condolences
on them okay Jake man Jake man I'll owe
you my life dude you're my fit and
brother call me and I'll be there
anytime anywhere
the hell was that one yeah I want to win
our pointment blah blah blah and empty
so that's a lot of counter-strike
actually I got a I got a crank up my
my mouse settings to quake grow mode how
do we get out here okay how do I get out
oh no I totally huh oh thank you all
right there we go
yeah back mild quick three days her
diary
I do not write English good no kidding
but my father insisted that I do this
American tradition of writing a diary
reading a diary he says it might help
make my English better I have no friends
yet I do not understand much when the
other children talk to me they talk too
fast and do not talk the same way grown
up too I will enter sixth grade soon I
am afraid I will not make many friends
or that others will not see me as one of
them I do not really miss Japan but I
had barely learned to write all the
kanjis for animals that I will now have
to learn how to write them here they
have less letters than us just looking
at this page makes me feel smarter oh
God
30 pages there this all right I'll uh
I'll get back to that later there's 30
pages of that diary and I'm not gonna
read that all in one chunk my whole
first episode would be all just being
readable I kick it out of my own house
calendar
good thing I'm not superstitious why oh
it's Friday 13 it's also 2013 for some
reason whatever new I need to go to the
garage right that's a thing I need to do
it's locked it's my house
where's be loud hello hello this what
what is it oh it's a bottle of booze
nope
like this hello September 11th 2001 uh
uh yep yep yep yep yep okay Oh missing
page oh it wasn't 30 pages I gotta find
the pages that's corrupt up
okay closing that of God come close
getting out here Alan cubbies
why was that so ominous they're just
kaze oh I thought it's awesome
funny story suddenly my headphones
started to work again they decided to
not be a douche carry go3 tutorial I
don't need a tutorial i'm way too smart
who are these magazines he's an awfully
low together much like vows I don't need
a tutorial to know how to maybe I'll
look at the tutorial
you can use the yes
sound effects or nests yeah
kick kicking them by pressing kill
that's all get out get out get out
never forget to use kick 1 out of ammo
or give you to push some heavy objects
okay alright I guess it was good at very
often your old counter - yeah ah crap I
got a battery meter for this that's a
very afraid of monsters s hello hey no I
want those please can I can I can I have
those I they look like batteries that's
fine be like that damn rinse enemy oh I
got to put my reticle like right on top
of yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh hello okay my dad's go
flying medicals ray oh yeah
Oh boom super juice hello drow Marc you
like interesting man this is a really
really really in-depth game okay f1 to
change camera
hi skip my dad concludes under how I
sorry for that little detour this is a
horror game by the way so this will get
scary once I get past it and flip it I
said
No
I wonder how long is it I assumed that
because it just said that it was like a
prologue or something that it wasn't
going to be very long but this might be
a lot longer than I thought it was okay
what do I do now I need to carry my gear
from the garage into the truck all right
I got the gear I thought well I thought
I got all the gear
yeah I did it's all in there oh there we
go ask if fine dark gain all right here
we go yes
and that's a good while
all part of the game I suppose I'm
actually kind of excited I haven't
encountered something India like this
with this much you know stuff to it in
awhile I now realize why I was so highly
rated and I'm actually quite excited
about this I actually don't know if it's
like a real horror game I think it's
horror
I believe it's horror the name under
[ __ ] hell suggests under [ __ ] under
hell suggest sense horror and I would be
inclined to believe that it is so let us
see
oh no and now we're back at the loading
screen again yes just you and me now
just you and me No
hi oh we're back 10 or 13th 2013
go
so time
without all the
Wall Street Way
from the parking lot
for in the bill
evaluation
this okay haha very clever I like
what the heck am I just
let's rock cyber am I
I can see everything through his camera
building a call right down that the
hospital fix it just take a left when
you reach the intersection giggle out
okay so I got to get to the building
from the hospital have a nice little
sniper rifle here take my spring who's
that oh I probably should kill those
guys but that guy looks like he's good
huh
they put a sniper rifle in my hand well
they expect me to not go on a rampage oh
yes sir mr. helmet cam man who's that
take a left you those guys are -
shouldn't I be hiding -
turn to the building okay on Matt what
you almost startled me waiting for you
on the top I almost blew your friggin
that up oh yeah taking a nap on the job
you make me sick all of you make me sick
bar you huh okay
like all main characters in these games
I'm going insane yeah
people to come at you man actually I'm
all out of time so I'm afraid that I'm
gonna have to cut it here before it is
before anything actually happened so
means you wanted to see us thank you all
so much for watching I hope to continue
this very soon and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye